[Inaudible].
The commentary Oregon's
[inaudible] [inaudible] door. We can gain mic
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Um, during, uh, do
[inaudible] fix it.
[inaudible] [inaudible] the party. Yep. Vide the party.
Your decor. [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] this home art full Vila food set apart it afterward,
or they then tank and some bad mama. We had the party outside the fleet.
[inaudible] restaurant millionaire and [inaudible] in Nikos. Some
[inaudible] through
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] so
[inaudible] dirt and some tide totally messed up.
And so someone listens do the blood.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] to her [inaudible] they attend the
[inaudible]. So again, mostly cosmetic greys and for establishing [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or what is good accountabili? Um,
so not Glaude up-slope and Familia on their whole name.
[inaudible] uh, so the Tictail or the Mosty or your, your,
can you this city [inaudible] or
divorced my tax free, man.
[inaudible] [inaudible] what Villalba, um,
[inaudible] song or, okay. But if we forget the score, I don't know.
No one I've done.
More, do more [inaudible].
For validity India, they can do a rapport.
[Inaudible].
I was taking medicine. I still would. I gave most of our practice.
That is in [inaudible]. Uh, yeah. Yeah.
[inaudible] go ahead. Directly.
The, the co the Camille [inaudible].
Okay, man, through the comment on, uh,
on non-common new Domi [inaudible] or default,
we'll see. Um.
Yeah.
Oh, it it's. So
[inaudible] and Heidi
[inaudible] to the heart, the response [inaudible] responsible.
[inaudible].
Oh, yesterday you don't mind.
[inaudible] so long cargo with. Yep.
Well, today I have terrible. [inaudible] just.
Uh.
[Inaudible] uh, I said
[inaudible].
I'm native or [inaudible].
Go ahead.
[inaudible].
In fact, this [inaudible] leads to Claude from
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] Mr.
[inaudible] [inaudible] um,
[inaudible] [inaudible] none for me. And it's like,
[inaudible] tiny studio. [inaudible].
You see it out of the, uh, do or
[inaudible].
Well, then they hide in musical Clyde either.
[inaudible] your, your bunny man, the, uh, heart
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] maybe [inaudible].
[Inaudible] story.
[inaudible] I'll go on until later tonight.
Uh,
[inaudible] feeling, Oh, my Camberfield scratch. Socks are not dirty.
So we automate tests and man
[inaudible] takes on the best day. That's uncommon first.
Just notice the
[inaudible] [inaudible] you know, [inaudible].
Um, yeah. Tank to become [inaudible] for [inaudible]
your,
I saw do away sex femme or,
um, okay. For let's. Uh that's no, yeah, yeah, no.
[inaudible] historically for me and not men, men, men
[inaudible] it's about [inaudible] um, mum
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
um,
[inaudible] yeah.
[Inaudible] or do you have a top of the
[inaudible] or for, for
[inaudible] [inaudible].
You're also your heart. Uh
[inaudible] uh,
or they don't want swore or get tanked. Uh,
dad be absolute in the, uh, fishermen now.
Um,
[inaudible] we are taking out Atlanta,
some Syria as we moved the
[inaudible] [inaudible] the lumberyard and I really didn't there.
It must've throw organism. Tanto Elisa red Duffer and personally our layers.
Can I [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] three. Get through all of the dorm and out via at Menin.
Did they have the lemon now for the asset without value
on who? On their [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] lost or damaged condition with press or more?
[inaudible].
You know, the, the, well, it's hard to say, um, uh,
didn't complex or get this wardrobe, uh,
man then feeling good. Are you among Highlander or
our, uh, [inaudible] or catch a fanfare out?
The deal started in Oregon.
He saw that
[inaudible] we can gas go. Ooh, controversial [inaudible] attitude.
It's for
[inaudible] constant theater at Mount hor mean genitalia or
[inaudible] or those gave it on mute and medicines.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Do, uh, this goal either three,
our makers was COVID blunt down in Nome. Uh, then
[inaudible], um,
[inaudible] of four, four, 10, uh, in Monterey campus.
Yo [inaudible] aye.
[Inaudible] um, uh, for the tank
[inaudible] at
[inaudible] or the
[inaudible] farrier or detail for your son or somebody. Awesome.
[inaudible] segregate at some hell.
[inaudible] Landa
[inaudible] at [inaudible]. Um,
so door contact
[inaudible] [inaudible] interview on a or
[inaudible].
Oh.
[Inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] comport. I hope may we some on some,
a Palestinian or some [inaudible].
So how many are [inaudible].
[Inaudible] okay. Hmm
[inaudible] Oh boy. Proton. And I ask a 400 or more
[inaudible] men. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] overheard Alex on firsthand from non-STEM from COVID. I feel one.
I'll take it then when we go about it.
[inaudible] [inaudible] man. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] Blind date.
The one tip is blind date.
The dating that I era men, men,
the at bro. Okay. Ankle set, hands fast.
The hack can be or early hoop because scaffolds and then blonde,
Omnia and Landa, or for her who it chance Acoma desire.
Some emanda.
Are a fantastic
[inaudible]. Thanks.
[Inaudible].